bonjour à tous vous connaissez surtout
comme économiste mais ici je ne vais pas
parler comme économiste mais je vais
m'exprimer comme universitaire et
citoyen engagé
j'ai toujours mené mes combats
politiques sous le double parrainage de
Charles de Gaulle et de Pierre Mendès
France Charles de Gaulle c'est bien sûr
le redressement du pays en 58 et Dieu
sait qu'on va avoir besoin de
redressement dans la situation
économique dans laquelle nous sommes
c'est évidemment aussi une certaine idée
de la France que nous partageons et
c'est également
la volonté de reconstruire ce pays qui a
joué un rôle absolument clé dans
l'histoire de l'Europe guerre Mendès
France et la vérité en politique si je
décide aujourd'hui de vous rejoindre
c'est parce que je partage les valeurs
qui ont été exprimées par Nicolas
Sarkozy dans plusieurs interventions
récentes la première valeur clé c'est la
liberté mais de quelle liberté
parle-t-on la liberté on en parle
continuellement en France
mais la liberté en réalité ça doit la
liberté des républicains c'est la
liberté des Romains des Grecs c'est la
liberté des lumières c'est donc la
liberté qui est fondée sur la
responsabilité la liberté et la
responsabilité sont les deux faces de la
même pièce
la liberté des républicains n'a rien à
voir avec la liberté de la gauche qui
est la liberté de l'irresponsabilité la
liberté des républicains c'est celle
dont la France a besoin aujourd'hui pour
se reconstruire
mais la République c'est également le
mérite et la recherche continue de
l'excellence c'est-à-dire exactement
l'inverse de ce qui a conduit à la
réforme récente du collège où on essaye
d'évacuer tout ce qui reste de mérite et
d'excellence et donc nous devons
reconstruire absolument une école fondée
sur le mérite et sur la recherche de
l'excellence
le la République la République c'est
également la valorisation du travail et
la liberté d'entreprendre dans des
combats que Nicolas Sarkozy a mené et
qu'il continue de mener
là aussi ce sont les deux phases de la
même pièce nous avons besoin comme pour
la liberté d'insister qui ne peut pas y
avoir de travail sans responsabilité
mais également sans reconnaissance du
travail qui a été accompli
et la République c'est évidemment
l'identité j'ai longtemps vécu à
l'étranger j'ai vécu aux États-Unis en
Angleterre j'ai beaucoup voyagé en
Allemagne à chaque fois j'ai été surpris
de ce que la France soit le seul pays
dans lequel on ne puisse pas affirmer
son identité française c'est parce que
nous sommes une grande nation une des
plus grandes civilisations de l'histoire
que nous ne devons pas renoncer à
affirmer notre identité française
l'autre le dernier point que je veux
évoquer ici c'est et qui me conduit à
vous rejoindre c'est que la situation du
pays est très grave on nous répète sans
arrêt que nous bénéficions d'un
alignement des planètes mais personne ne
le voit les petits entrepreneurs ne le
voient pas les artisans ne voient pas la
reprise bien sûr c'est le fruit de
l'écrasement fiscal qui a été mis en
oeuvre au début de ce quinquennat dans
ce moment grave donc nous avons besoin
tous de nous affirmer comme républicain
nous avons besoin d'invoquer la liberté
la responsabilité le mérite et
l'excellence l'autorité l'exemplarité le
combat va être dur il va être rude mais
les républicains ont du cœur vivent la
République des républicains en vive la
France